hi developers and welcome to serverless
migration station where we show you one
serverless compute modernization
technique i'm wesley from google joined
by martin and our friend porter here to
discuss how and when you would move an
app engine app to cloud functions that
sounds great but what i want to know is
why we'd want to migrate an app engine
app to cloud functions
very fair of you to ask because you want
to know whether it's worth doing one key
reason is that you didn't have much code
to begin with but app engine was all we
had available other reasons include less
configuration more robust local
development experience and the ability
to do event-based background processing
wow i didn't even know you could do this
with cloud functions
but isn't app engine really different
from cloud functions yeah it seems that
way doesn't it i mean app vision is
great for full stack web apps or mobile
back-ends while cloud functions sounds
like it's for event-driven microservices
or one-off utility functions right yeah
that's exactly right wes so i suppose
answering when you'd move from app
engine to cloud functions is the first
order of business before discussing how
to do it
absolutely anytime you're considering
switching products you don't do it
lightly i already mentioned some of the
benefits you get with cloud functions
but for something more specific i'd say
we take a quick step back
there was a time not too long ago when
app engine was the only serverless
platform available so you'd use it for
everything including small single
functionality apps if you call them that
short apps with not much code are
perfect for this migration cloud
functions has much less overhead meaning
you can drop app.yaml and other
configuration files keeping just your
app files along with third-party package
dependencies oh and one other thing
cloud functions does not support python
2 so this is a great chance to upgrade
to python 3. ah that makes sense a small
app like that is really just a single
microservice perfect for cloud functions
cool so what was the other situation for
considering moving from app engine to
cloud functions well you said the magic
word martin microservice in this other
scenario you have a huge monolithic app
made up of mostly independent routes
which could be almost a collection of
api endpoints oh uh so you mean i can
split out my user authentication code
and admin only utilities to be separate
functions
away from the main app that's right
especially if you have different
developers doing the auth code the
database code the admin code and so on
your dev team won't be stepping on each
other's shoes breaking up that app into
multiple independent microservices like
what you suggested is a prime candidate
to move to cloud functions better yet if
you make them plug and play you can
reuse those pieces for other apps saving
time and improve maintainability it's a
valuable refactor in many respects
sounds good
but what if my monolithic application is
huge and have a ton of microservices
would that still be a good use case for
cloud functions
it's a good question martin the general
rule of thumb for using cloud functions
is when you have a few or a handful of
microservices if you've got many more
than that or there are even dependencies
between them you may want to consider
keeping it running as is on app engine
for now or consider moving to cloud run
especially if your team has added
containerization as part of your
software development workflow makes
sense
and if that's the case we've already
made some videos showing users how to
migrate from app engine to cloud run
both with and without docker right
that's right and both of those videos
also come with code labs so you get that
hands-on experience the rest of this
video will be for those considering
cloud functions instead
sounds good can you tell us more about
the app we're migrating to cloud
functions yeah the cloud ndb sample app
from module 2 is a great example for us
to use because it doesn't rely on any
app engine bundled services we moved it
from app engine ndb to cloud ndb back in
module 2 and since cloud functions only
supports python 3 we're going to start
with the module 2b folder and migrate
that app to cloud functions i see
can you point me to the repo as well as
the codelab to remind me what we did
back in module 2. sure thing here are
the links to both the starting repo as
well as the codelab to remind you of how
we got there from module 1. if you did
module 2 and ported it to python 3 start
with your version but if you don't have
it clone the repo or download the zip
file and grab it from the module 2b
folder got it now i understand that i
should use cloud functions when i have
smaller bits of code like utility
function or microservice rather than a
full app
is there anything else to know when
getting ready to migrate
yeah well think about this if you don't
have a full app you won't need a full
web framework either right
yes you still have to get service and
respond to requests but that's it
you can just write code and not have to
think about stacks or frameworks with
that
so let's go to the computer and move
this to cloud functions now
you know the pattern by now right deploy
that app one more time to app engine to
ensure it works this way there's no
guessing if you run into issues after
migrating from your module 2b
run gcloud app deploy and confirm that
your app adds a new visit and displays
the 10 most recent visits just like it's
always done
ok just like when we migrated from app
engine cloud run it's a whole new
platform so make an entire copy of your
module 2b folder
now let's start cleaning house delete
app.yaml and app engine artifact the
only config file needed is the package
requirements file requirements.txt
neither that nor the html index file in
templates require editing
all of the work is in the main
application file and when i say work it
sounds like a lot but it's really just
removing or tweaking things as mentioned
earlier we don't need a web framework so
strip out almost everything from flask
the app still renders a template of
visits so we do need to keep that
cloud functions will give us a flask
request object when the cloud functions
is called so we don't need to ask the
framework for it
we removed importing flash so there's no
need to instantiate it no there's no
longer an app object if your app is
dependent on it you may be better off
staying with app engine or
containerizing it for cloud run
no app means we should remove the route
as well while root is an adequate name
for the root function of an app this app
is really just a single function visit
me since it's now a function let's give
it an appropriate function name visit me
cloud functions will call it directly
with that name plus it's more
descriptive and boom that's it your app
engine app is now a cloud function
instead of gcloud app deploy is gcloud
functions deploy
but because cloud functions doesn't have
a config file like app.yaml you need to
specify other aspects like which runtime
the trigger type whether to allow
unauthenticated traffic and possibly
what region
now as you wrap up let's chat about some
things that cloud functions can do that
app engine can't one key feature is that
while you can develop cloud functions on
the command line like app engine you can
also do everything in the browser create
functions code them deploy them and test
them all from the cloud console pretty
cool right martin
wow that is really cool
sometimes i'm on the road and really
only have browser access it's good to
know that i'll be able to make fixes
from my hotel room if needed
i think there's another thing cloud
functions can do that app engine can't
right
yeah and perhaps this is a product
differentiator we know app engine apps
are http triggered well cloud function
supports that but now we can execute our
function in the background as part of an
event-driven process cloud functions can
be triggered if someone uploads a file
to cloud storage a new message comes in
the cloud pub sub someone logs into
firebase and so on right
it's cool that event driven means you
can execute different cloud functions as
part of one single workflow
uh now you mentioned we can develop
deploy and test in the browser but i'm
really an old-school developer
what if i want to do everything here on
my local laptop yeah the cloud functions
team has you covered here too for local
development and testing check out the
functions framework a set of open source
libraries letting you create lightweight
functions that run in many different
environments including cloud functions
locally on your laptop like you wanted
cloud run or other k-native-based
environments check it out with the links
down below
all right cloud functions is quite the
versatile product i'll definitely
consider it for its target use cases and
now are there any other migrations that
app engine developers should consider
yeah most of the videos in this
migration series involves migrating off
of the original app engine bundle
services like switching away from app
engine db to either cloud ndb or cloud
datastore and those are covered in
modules 2 and 3. those with app engine
push queues can migrate those to cloud
tasks this is covered in modules 7 8 and
9.
modules 12 and 13 cover moving off of
app engine memcache to cloud memory
store and redis and we already discussed
containerizing app engine apps for cloud
run with or without docker and those are
featured in modules four and five
wow so many modules was i'm not supposed
to do each module one after another
right that's right and more of them are
coming developers should look at
whichever modules make the most sense
for their apps and use cases we're here
whenever you need us thanks for riding
with us on portal for all of these
different migration journeys this is
wesley from google cloud on behalf of
martin and porter and we hope to see you
at the next migration station or on
another serverless expedition soon
[Music]
you